another question from Reddit uh ask
David to explain why American style
libertarianism is an unserious
philosophy I don't know what they mean
by American style libertarianism I've
talked before about these kind of
utopian Libertarians where uh you know
we have we don't have police you just
kind of like hire a for-profit company
if you want protection and if there's a
conflict between two of these private
security companies then I don't know you
figure it out somehow so it's almost
like anarchism
if by I don't know what the question
means by that American style
libertarianism but in general my
problems with libertarianism as it is
often presented
come from the work of Sociology as well
as human psychology which is the reality
that once you get a group that's bigger
than 150 people
you really have to start centralizing
some decisions unless you're going to
subdivide the 150 endlessly into 275s
that now no longer have contact but then
that's not really one Society now it's
two I've not seen good evidence and I've
read a fair bit about this that once you
get Beyond 150 you can keep all
decisions decentralized and once you say
some things need to be centralized then
it's a matter of how you do it and it's
going to be some version of government
that conflicts with aspects of
libertarianism
well it could be companies right it
could be it could be more Market driven
which is the idea of anarchism that
you're not you don't give any
centralized entity of Monopoly over
violence
you know and then if you think that the
markets are efficient
at delivering especially in this 21st
century and beyond
where a market could have perfect
information about people so one of the
issues is that you can manipulate
markets because there's not perfect
information but now in the digital age
we can uh we could be
higher bandwidth participants in the
market so if you're choosing between
different security companies or you're
choosing between different providers
different Services you can do so more
efficiently and more effectively
and in the digital space so you could
kind of imagine it but we haven't
successfully done it
uh without governments yeah and I think
there's a practical once you get Beyond
150 you also start specializing
um it just is a matter of fact you don't
have everybody isn't growing their own
food some people grow the food and other
people do other things and you come
across a lot of the problems that
started at the Agricultural Revolution
and whether you say that it's a company
that's solving it or a government the
problems are going to be very similar
and I've not read anything that to my
satisfaction explains how you deal with
that well there's underlying principles
of libertarianism which is putting
priority at the freedom of the
individual right
and that's a compelling
notion yeah whenever I do these various
political Compass things that put you on
two axes on the authoritarian
libertarian axis I am way down on the
libertarian side as a left libertarian
so my Tendencies are always
anti-authoritarian and and
towards that option when it makes sense
so I sympathize with that a lot